our next guest went viral for sharing
incredible self-protection tips that we
all need to know he is a former first
class marine in the royal netherlands
marine corp and here's a look at his
tips on how to punch
when you got nails watch this desire to
throw a punch with acrylics on my last
video you saw me rolling up my fingers
like this to create a fist obviously you
can do that and it hurts very very much
so here's how to throw punch okay please
welcome robin hunting
thank you for coming thank you for
having me bobby
did you know
like doing this that it would catch on
like wildfire i had a feeling because
you don't see it a lot so i had a
feeling that it was gonna go viral i
mean i don't um wear nails i did for
this character i played on santa clarita
diet i did big long nails and it really
it changes your whole disposition and
body language all of a sudden i was
talking with my hands and i felt like 10
inches longer but that being said
i know and work with women who really
care about their nails so this is
brilliant that you put this out here
okay will you teach us absolutely if one
does have nails so we'll grab one of
these so you can actually do it so
obviously when you have want to make a
fist you can't really crawl it in right
because this is how you make a proper
fist you can't do that with nails yeah
you can't make a fist what else
surprised you when you first put nails
on about what life was like also like if
you yeah lancer ross is here the first
thing i realized is you should not put
your wallet in your back pocket when you
get your nails because i couldn't get it
out
yeah what about texting could you do
that oh you're you're kind of like
swiping left like opening doors was
difficult things you don't think about
until you got nails right exactly um
also like if you
hold your fingers in certain positions
when you punch you can really hurt your
fingers so you have to protect them yes
absolutely so if you would move it like
that and then punch it's not natural and
you you have a space in here so you
could break your fingers so what i
suggest is you move your hand a little
bit down like this kind of like this you
bend it a little bit and you're going to
strike with right here oh
so you don't actually break any nails
and you still do a lot of damage so
you're going to palm him exactly yeah
okay
yeah sure
going gonna strike right here with that
ow it's good well it's the
that's really good
i'm gonna try it
here
a little bit of your shoulder really put
it in yeah
there's two techniques i'm gonna try
another one
all right i'm getting into this i'm
going my nails out let's go so try to
move your fingers like this like that
yeah you're gonna strike with this side
you can do like a hammer fist alright so
try it with that arm and you're to slide
strike in here okay ready so you're
going to move yeah go like that okay so
like you're that's good yeah yeah one
two three one more three two
look
i didn't even break a nail
but i kicked your butt wait definitely
did
um before you go what is your top safety
tip that everyone should know so
carry a bobby pin it gets you out of me
in many uh handcuffs or you can pick a
lock with it and then carry shoelaces
because if you were ever zip tied or you
have duct tape around if you do it in a
seesaw motion you can burn through it
because it has a melting point
i didn't know any of that
you're good
thank you robin
and thank you for everything
that you're doing out in the world by
helping people protect themselves it's
very empowering and obviously people are
really responding to it it is thank you
so much for having me thank you
you can find him on our website and make
sure to follow him for more safety tips
we'll be right back
[Music]